was it the Wolverine origin movie that
you had to do the running naked down the
corridor I know there was x-men 2 okay
yeah no actually no first day of x-men
origins RN naked I seem to you I quite
enjoy it really it's a very freeing
feeling I saw I saw Ron take your
clothes off it's what should we do it
running game so I remember we had to go
down this hallway and I had to run I was
meant to be naked and and it was very
dark and and I jokingly went in and I
said I want a closed set for this and
the first idea was laughing anyway went
to the first take and I'm running that's
a very intense scene where I first
realize having adamantium skeleton I've
been experimenting I'm naked there's
blood I'm like ah and as I run around
the corner the first ad had the entire
crew or two females all the females with
like $5.00 okay
and of course the first thing I did was
I cut myself oh when you see you know
you mean I'll actually be Mumbai
thankfully my circumcision yeah I did
the guy Elvis is pg-13 so you can't have
bits and pieces flying about right yeah
the census in America don't like that
kind of stuff that could in as my rap
gear from from Bryan Singer the director
he gave me a bag and was a little bag
and was very light I looked inside a
head film inside and I'm like let's feel
when I look up okay that's my bit my
bits in you've all the classic
you've got the classic Paul then the
boys have also come up with Scott of
those signature poses so James yours is
the the finger okay
fingering my brain yeah wasn't much was
there much discussion about that or did
you just kind of go Oliver's did it I
still I thought I thought Patrick never
did it he's missed a beat
and also that you know there's a lot of
with that when he utilizes his power
there's a lot of that closer to him gone
that's not dynamic but you know what is
this number 16 that's the route did you
and Patrick discuss it is Patrick a bit
miffed but now you've come up with a bit
of a dynamic action I myself move no
he's happy not to finger himself but he
has said if I would like to everything
room and place my fingers or knees heads
yes but in this movie you get to meet
Paz do I get to go nose-to-nose with
Patrick shirt so were you did you have
to not real consciously because in the
first film that was never gonna happen
so in this one were you watch more
conscious of I'm gonna to turn into
Baxter in a minute no I was kind of
ignoring the fact that anybody else had
ever played it and even when I was going
face to face with him I was still trying
to pretend that he's only ever meet is
ever gonna play the part he's being
modest by the way he it was his first
day and he had about a three-page scene
one of the pivotal scenes in the movie
and it was phenomenal I'm at that point
meant to be unconscious and I was on
you're always on camera so it's been one
of those looking and it was for not he
is absolutely brilliant and your first
day it was honestly you should clap it
as he is a genius
seriously though you should clap it KITT
Michael were you the same were you kind
of thinking oh god you know Ian McKellan
in a minute it's gotta be him
yeah a voice in stun yeah well I just
sort of steel
I stole everything from him and no I I
didn't actually get to do a scene with
him we had to toss a coin it was either
a me Andy a no Patrick so I just got to
meet him in comic-con but I'd spent sort
of quite a lot of time watching there's
a there's a clip of him on YouTube
giving actually a workshop on
Shakespeare and on the Scottish play
which I was ending up sort of gonna be
doing after well just just finished it
now so it was kind of weird but I just
listened to that on a loop it's about
ten minutes long and it's a young
younger ian mckellen and tell us about
your your signature pose did you discuss
it or did you just come up with yourself
no I just thought you know I figured
jazz hands
combined with the suitable level of
constipation I thought that correct
intensity no I just say you're not that
right here's a picture of I know I'm not
wrong that's what I was doing
see I'm actually sitting on a toilet
isn't on paper my face with you is like
oh no good you know you're you're sick
you're going it's working it's coming no
I like I like James's face it this we
good who's James Joseph yep it's working
dammit
and Michael does look like he could
burst into song at any time
I've seen the fanart no have you serious
I show sometimes what you should enjoy I
showed that but there's other ones like
doesn't this is nice is that you were
reading this is hahaha